now you also told that story on Rogan
about eating the rats this is a very
disturbing story but I want you to try
to explain it people were dying in these
hospitals and rats would eat the
eyeballs of the people who were dying
and children who are starving would eat
the rats and then the children would die
the rats and eat the children I do need
to know because I grew up in New York
City and there are tons of rats in New
York City yep you also moved here you
went to school here yeah was it were
there ever times where you saw rats and
you were like you know brought it back
one time did you think about that at all
just because it's old habits
because they were so much bigger than
North Korea are there anything you miss
like would you consume any of that stuff
now
oh hang on